people send me tons of stuff and I have
to go through it and look at them and
find their funny or not what amuses me
is something which is unusual or is a
different angle on something and a
different take on something under for
originality I'm look of an idea that
hasn't been done before and i'm looking
for something which is striking in some
way so it's best to it's best to do
jokes about people you nail them you're
doing somewhere your mother and raw or
the bank manager or anything like that
The Spectator is giving out a cartoon
award we're trying to find new
cartoonists are preferably funny but
you've seen the way I am so taking the
notice of that and be funny on her own
account because I'm sure he has lares
your parents and stitches I'm assuming
you're young with no need to be
cartooning as very seldom covered by
women women don't do cartoons so I'd
like lots of women to do them preferably
drawings of men they hate this trip you
very easy to do husbands and things like
that so you could be extremely amusing
and get rid of all your frustrations on
the page and send them to me and I will
look at them kindly and over a cool cup
of coffee be very relaxed about it and
pay you vast sums of money and you could
be a regular cartoonist of the magazine
and take over when I fall off my peg
pitch puch puch